على مدى الأسابيع الستة الماضية ، كان كيفان سامادهي في
حالة فرار
كل ليلة ينتقل إلى منزل آمن آخر
تعرض للتعذيب الوحشي لمدة 21 يومًا على
يد النظام الإيراني ، فهو
مرعوب من أنهم سيجدون جريمته
ينظم المسعفين لمساعدة
المتظاهرين الجرحى ولكن حتى  مع خوفه من
أن يتم تعقبه ، شخص ما لا يزال يريد
أن يعرّف عن نفسه أنه يريد أن يُظهر
للنظام أنهم لم يكسروه. لقد
أنشأت مجموعة من الأطباء السريين
عالجنا حوالي 700 شخص
كان النظام يرتكب جرائم حرب
ويمنع علاج الجرحى.
وعد أصدقائي بالقتال من أجلهم ، حيث
نزل أصدقاؤه مثل العديد من الإيرانيين
في الشوارع للاحتجاج على
نظام الملالي الذي فرض حياتهم لفترة طويلة
من أجل أن
قبضت
قوات الأمن الإيرانية على طالب في كلية الطب وتم نقله إلى الأسود.
موقع منشأة استجواب سرية
خارج نطاق سيادة القانون حيث
يقول العديد من الناجين لشبكة CNN إن
الاعترافات القسرية تم انتزاعها من خلال
أكثر أساليب التعذيب وحشية ،
وقد استخدمت اعترافات هؤلاء الأربعة أحيانًا
في المحكمة لإعدام متظاهرين على
جرائم ضد الدولة رفضت الصمادي
التوقيع على ما قاله.  أعتقد أنه سيكون
مذكرة وفاته ،
لماذا يجب أن أوقع على شيء
لم أفعله أنا لست إرهابيًا ولست
قاتلاً أو مخربًا ، لقد أنقذت
الأرواح فقط هذا هو فريقي ولم أفعل
شيئًا بخلاف العديد من
ضحايا التعذيب الآخرين  أن CNN قابلت
شخصًا ما لم يكن معصوب العينين أثناء
احتجازه بناءً على شهادته ،
كلفت CNN بالصور التالية
لأخذك إلى داخل المحنة التي
تعرض لها هو والعديد من المتظاهرين الإيرانيين الآخرين ،
حيث
تم إجباري على دخول مبنى مخبأ
بالأشجار
بجوار فتيات  المدرسة
في اليوم الأول ، ركلني الحارسان ، كنت
أتقيأ دما كل يوم كان التعذيب
يزداد سوءا ، كانت هناك خزانة في
زاوية الغرفة مليئة
بأدوات التعذيب ، ماشية كهربائية تحث على قطع مختلفة ،
بعض الحقن التي خدروها لي ،
أرادوا أن أبقى على قيد الحياة لفترة أطول
عذبني أكثر ، بدأ الحارس
يقبّلني ويلعق رقبتي ، فقد
لمسوا أعضائي التناسلية وأردافي
في اليوم السادس عشر من اعتقالي ،
نزلت إلى الجحيم ،
لكن بعضنا
أودعوا يديّ وكبلوا ساقيّ وأرادوا
كسرها لتدميرها.  لقد
سحبوا سروالي إلى أسفل
ظننت أنهم سيصعقونني
بصدمة كهربائية مرة أخرى
لم أصدق أنهم سيفعلون ذلك ،
أخذ الخفاش وذهب خلفي
كنت أنتظر أن أتعرض للضرب وقبل
رقبتي و  دفع العصا
في شرجي
وقال إن هذا ما
يفعله جنود الثورة الأمريكيون للمثليين من الفتيان مثلك ، لقد
صُدمت ولم أكن أعرف ماذا أفعل
لم أستطع حتى الصراخ لقد كنت مذهولًا
وبكيت في صمت.
انظر إلى
دوائر الفلك حول عينيك ،
هل تنام ، أعني أنا
آسف ،
يعتقد شخص ما أنه إذا وقع على
الاعتراف الكاذب كما أرادته الآلهة ،
فسيشنقه
بتهمة الخيانة ،
ولا يعرف سبب
إطلاق سراحه.  يعتقد أنهم أرادوه
أن يموت في الشوارع تحذيرًا مروعًا
للآخرين
استنادًا إلى شهادة شهود عيان مفصلة من شخص ما
والإحالة المرجعية مع
صور الأقمار الصناعية وقد تمكنت سي إن إن من
تحديد الموقع الأسود حيث يقول إنه
تعرض للتعذيب في مسقط رأسه في
أوشينافيا.
هي الأشجار التي تخفي
المبنى المجهول الذي تم إحضاره إليه
وهذه هي مدرسة البنات حيث سمع
الأطفال يلعبون في الفناء
ولكن هذا ليس الموقع الأسود الوحيد الذي
يحيل إلى شهادة من أكثر من
عشرين مصدرًا مع صور الأقمار الصناعية
وجدت سي إن إن العشرات من  هذه المواقع السوداء
التي يمكن تقسيمها إلى نوعين من
السجون غير القانونية غير المصرح بها داخل
المنشآت الحكومية مثل
القواعد العسكرية ومراكز الاستخبارات والسجون
السرية المؤقتة التي
تظهر بشكل مؤقت بالقرب من
مواقع الاحتجاج على سبيل المثال في هذه المدينة
المعروفة بمواقع الحج الدينية التي كانت
موجودة فيها.  استخدام بعض المساجد
كمراكز احتجاز وفقًا
لمصادر متعددة تحدثت بها CNN مع هذا النمط يمكن
رؤيته في مدن مختلفة في جميع أنحاء
البلاد في سان أنداج ، وجدنا ما لا يقل عن
ستة مراكز احتجاز غير رسمية zahidan
5 والعاصمة حيث تمكنت CNN أيضًا
من تحديد ثمانية مواقع مختلفة.  -على
مواقع التعذيب بعد التحدث إلى العشرات
من شهود العيان الذين تعرضوا للتعذيب في
مراكز الاعتقال غير الرسمية المختلفة هذه ، لم تكن المعاملة الهمجية التي استخدمها
السمادهي فريدة من نوعها. تجربته
مع شهادات شهود عيان أخرى
وصفتني بوقاحة فرك نفسه عارياً مرة أخرى
وأيديهم مقيدة الإذلال
لا خيار آخر  لكن للاعتراف في مجموع CNN
بوجود أكثر من ثلاثين
سجنًا سريًا في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، فإنه يرسم
صورة لنظام يواجه التعذيب
على نطاق صناعي مصمم لسحق
انتفاضة شكلت أكبر
تهديد وجودي للنظام منذ
عقود.
فقط بعض
المتظاهرين الذين عالجهم طبيب مستشفى الدولة
الدكتور مارتن سارافي وزملاؤه
في مدينة سنندج نقطة
اشتعال رئيسية في قمع
الانتفاضة كان عملاً غير قانوني وفقًا
للنظام الإيراني لأنه
تم إحضاره أيضًا إلى موقع أسود  ويتعرضون للتعذيب
هم قوة في حد ذاتها
ولا يتبعون أي نوع من
حقوق الإنسان ولا يوجد إشراف ما نوع
الإشراف الذي يجب أن تتمتع به عندما
يتعرض الأشخاص للاغتصاب وليس لديهم
أي حدود أخلاقية يريدونك فقط
أن تعترف حتى يتمكنوا من مقاضاتك ، الدكتور
سرابي الآن أيضًا مختبئًا ، وكان عليك
أن تخاطر كثيرًا لمجرد القيام بعملك
إذا بكيت ، فهذا ليس لأنني أخشى أن
الجمهورية الإسلامية ليس بسبب
ما فقدته بل بسبب القسوة
أن الناس في إيران يواجهون
حتى مع وجود أدلة على التعذيب على
نطاق صناعي تشير إلى
يأس النظام ،
يتم تعريف المتظاهرين الشباب في إيران بشكل متساوٍ حتى في
مواجهة التعذيب والموت الذي لا يمكن تصوره
CNN